okay sure yeah it's absolutely my
decision Mick Mulvaney and I've been
talking about it for a few weeks we I've
been looking ahead to it to this summer
for quite some time because the history
of the CEA is that the CH air changes
about every two years I think that
President Clinton had four CEA chairs of
up gotta great President Bush had five
President Obama had four and I think
that that turnover if you study the
institution is very important because
CEA is meant to be kind of like CBO this
objective adviser and the longer you
stay here the closer you get with
everybody and maybe the harder it is to
be objective and so I think it's a
celebration really of the organization
it's important for CEA chairs to leave
after two years
yeah I told President Trump last week we
spoke at the back room at the end of the
day maybe was there for about half an
hour and we had a really pleasant
friendly conversation I think his tweet
kind of reflects the strength of our
relationship and we're about a little
bit sad but I think it's time for me to
move on and this ei is going to be in
really strong hands
the president's looking at a number of
candidates but we've got a big powerful
team built for next year and so the CEA
will continue to function well
the president mentioned that he was
going to name the replacement as soon as
he got back and I would expect the